eu vou cadê o cabo é 60 watts quando tem mais é
E aí, sabe o leite?
Sabe o leite.
E a parte que eu vou tomar agora?
E a sua água, foi?
A sua água?
Ainda não.
A gente não está nem pensando em ter ela no limite.
Porque o cara chega lá e tem que colocar a pele.
Mas a gente vai ter que fazer a reclusão, tá ligado?
Só que para tirar as costas da lua.
Para tirar as costas que estão no jeito.
Enfim.
Então...
Tipo assim, não estou justificativo para essa
construção, não.
Mas aí, por erro mesmo, dá risco.
É só assim.
Aquela grande arma que você fez com...
Foi real, mas...
Esqueci, né?
Esqueci agora.
Desperta e desligada.
Sim, é. Aí foi mais ou menos, né?
Ah, deve ter afrouxado o negócio.
Não, não é isso.
Na verdade, ela levantava a polícia, né?
É, foi afrouxado.
É?
Você não acha que tem que colocar...
Pela música.
Olha o grinder
Está bem?
Está triste
Vai se molhar, não?